you know the film is based on Tudor
stories really eight first year stories
eight years ago my oldest brother passed
away and he left behind an eleven year
old daughter and my wife and I adopted
her and moved her from Tennessee to
Sherman Oaks California and we put her
in a Catholic school Notre Dame High
School and in her sophomore year and her
world religion class she gets a homework
assignment find a catholic saint that
inspires you and find someone in your
real life that mimics the qualities of
that saint and she picks a million of
rochester the pages they have adopted
children who Oliver pics in the movie
and she picked me and that's the movie
except it wouldn't be me it'd be a drunk
Bill Murray again and the secondary
story is Vincent's character is based on
my father my father-in-law who is my
wife's father obviously and and he was a
Vietnam vet and an alcoholic and you
know I had like five kids and abandon
them all it was just not a good person
and then stop talking to my wife when
she was 9 and then 25 years later my
wife goes to one of those you know find
your life weekend seminars in Los
Angeles
800 bucks if you want to go and she gets
this assignment almost like a a get
complete with the people in your life
make amends so she writes his dear dad
letter and Mail's at the East Longmeadow
Massachusetts address she finds two
weeks later the phone rings Kim it's
your dad and she just starts crying and
I got to see that relationship become a
father-daughter relationship with him
fall in love and have each other for the
last 10 years of his life and he became
her saint and vice versa and I just was
so inspired by that relationship that's
why that's why I want to prevent it
certainly must feel like a great bit of
serendipity when you find a young actor
that can pull off a role that with all
the demands that this one has that's a
big challenge when you start with a
story like this isn't it yeah it's
completely terrifying to me you're just
paralyzed with fear that you're not
gonna find the person who's gonna make
the whole movie really work which was
Jaden's character
1,600 kids to find Jaden so a lot of
kids yeah I think this is this was or
what was one of the was fun fun films to
shoot and there's amazing amazing people
that I worked with ten was amazing Jenna
was amazing and in being in New York for
the whole summer was was it was like I
feel so lucky to to work with these
people and and and in New York what
about directing Bill Murray working with
Bill Murray's like being a deer hunter
in a tree stand and when the deer comes
by if you're not ready you will miss the
deer that's what it's like working on
Bill Murray I thought you meant deer
hunter Lake so we all get in our tree
stand the 4:00 a.m. we wait for this
deer and then sometimes he comes it
seems to me that ethos um was most
interesting acting when he's not
speaking how do you handle something
like that as a director I didn't talk
much to Bill about that well I talked to
a little bit bill bill you know as bill
being the deer right you just kind of
guide you know you put out some salt
licks and the deer comes right you know
and so you say certain things I tried to
keep bill basically what Bill needed for
me was to know where he was in time and
space I mean literally like what scene
did I just come from I said oh well you
just came from this and you know this is
the sea and so you just keep him on
track
that way when you're dealing with Bill
Murray and Melissa McCarthy and Naomi
Watts hi personally think the less you
say the better otherwise you just
pollute what they naturally are bringing
to the table anyway I I was fascinated
with with Melissa doing this role and
I'm so proud of her that we get to see
her in this other light that I think is
fascinating and she knew what she was
doing from the start
and the same thing with Naomi
and crystal dad I mean you just you know
if you believe in it you get out of the
way and and I think the job is to get
out of the way
there's otherwise you just you you heavy
hand everything and and you just
contaminated what were the challenges
with this to get people to see a story
that's relatively small and it's telling
in rhythms but has a lot of big messages
it ends up always being about the
material so the experience of this film
was that we all read the script in our
office almost simultaneously like within
I would say twenty four hours of one
another which never happens
you know like assistants everybody
throughout the ranks and we were
completely overcome and realized this is
why we all get in the movie business and
this is the kind of film that we hope to
make one day and the true the same was
true for talent I mean you know the the
amount of talent that accrued so quickly
on this movie is a testament to how
powerful it is to have great stories I
mean that's what movies are so that part
was very easy and then figuring out the
financing and what have you you know
that's its own journey always but what
would you talk about the tonal
challenges and decisions you guys made
we decided early you know bill bill
would say this bill would say there's a
difference between sentiment and
sentimentality he goes you have written
honest sentiment about people that are
just honestly trying to get get through
the day and find a way sentimentality is
when you cross that line and you
manipulate so we tried our hardest I
don't know if we achieved it I've seen
the film 500 times I it's so long for me
right now but I don't know if we achieve
that but we tried hard to not cross that
line we didn't do sweeping moves and we
didn't we didn't do super close-ups we
didn't do all those things you see
that that you feel like you're being you
know guide they're you know pushed and
bill worked really hard it just just
trying to stay straight and ground the
film the same thing with Melissa it's
it's tricky subject matter because you
ultimately you know ultimately you know
where the films going right you know
where it's going it's not it's not a
thriller it's called st. Vincent so you
kind of know where it's going and so
it's it's about the journey and so the
journey we tried to keep as purist we
could all the actors
it's like Melissa didn't when they
played mostly didn't do anything broad
or anything maudlin she just kind of
played it you know right down the middle
and we always saw this drama with some
funny moments so that's what we were
trying to do and Jaden coming into the
the project after you read the script
got to know the character a little bit
was there a scene that you kind of
circled in your mind that you thought
you were really looking forward to or
one that you were gonna have to really
work extra hard to get it or just right
well Ted Mimi read the script 15 times
so I think I was I was ready or I think
I actually wasn't ready and I was um
looking forward to doing the speech
scene at the end well
because it's it's that was that's the
hardest thing to do in front of a bunch
of people and then it was about four
pages long it was it was really tough
but at the end it was it was exciting to
to to be done with it
but it was it turned out to I hope
hopefully turned out to be okay it did
turn out to be okay and the deer made it
home and everybody's safe
and thank you for coming out this
evening and thank you for st. Vincent
thanks for joining us